[Music]
[Music]
that's awesome
i'm an idiot it's not that awesome
the guy who was on the receiving end of
those lasers all year long after his
first year with the buffalo bills what a
difference a year makes our good friend
stefan diggs brought to us by our
friends at old spice stefan what's up
buddy
oh how you guys doing it's always nice
to see you good looking man man how are
things oh don't lie to him like that
stefan i'm good-looking he's not you
know that don't be a liar come on man
i gotta be batman somebody gotta be
superman you get it
that's it that's right hey uh so yeah i
think back to last year when we saw you
and of course we assumed you were still
going to be with the vikings we talked
about areas where the vikings need to
improve when was the moment
that you you made that decision i got to
make this change for the good of my
career
um
i won't say i considered it i i consider
it even then even then there was a
throat in my mind but um heading into
like the offseason and when things
already started rolling like trades and
stuff like that that's when i really
made the company get this concrete
decision but i was thinking about it for
a while you know even during the season
prior to the season
everybody involved knew what i was
thinking you know it was just you know
the world kind of caught in the back
all right so now you get to buffalo okay
what what was your thoughts of josh
allen
going in
and then your first day being on the
field with them and your thoughts after
that
well i didn't watch too many of buffalo
other than the time that they kicked our
butt uh during the season it came to
minnesota it was a well coached team a
team that um was ready to play and they
just beat us flat out they maybe was
like 30 something to like six or three
something like that so i've never seen a
i don't know what they say but they said
a lot of stuff going in when i first got
traded about josh allen divine accurate
or he does this he makes bad decisions
or whatever they were saying
i never saw you know even from training
camp on i never saw him make bad
decisions i always seen him throw darts
i always seem to be accurate um i've
never seen a nothing characteristic of a
quarterback i've been with so many
quarterbacks no quarterback is perfect
but he's damn near perfect i've seen him
miss maybe seven throws of the whole
season you know for me i never saw the
guy that they tried to paint him to be
and i kind of saw a lot of potential i
thought he's a young quarterback i've
been with a young quarterback before
even when i was young so as far as like
getting on the same page early is going
to be huge
in his development in my development you
know having some success in the league
is one thing but getting what a guy that
you can really grow with and work with
and deal with that's that's that's what
you really want were you were you
shocked by like the arm strength at
first like was that an adjustment
because i mean no you weren't at all you
you knew what you were getting into
yeah because i remember in the draft he
was coming out and everything everybody
was thinking about taking them high they
said you thought about 70 yards anybody
that could over send me 80 yards you
know what about 70 80 yards has a cannon
for arms so when i first got there uh he
was slinging and he was throwing it he
was throwing it pretty hard i was like
hey like take a little walk
yeah i didn't do nothing yeah you got to
throw it down hard sorry i was cracking
up something like you didn't even throw
the ball that hard he was just throwing
dart at me once twice during practice so
i get i got adjusted to that pretty
quick you know playing receiver you get
used to catching the ball but uh
definitely it was definitely something
different
yeah i want to go back to last year
because i'm reflecting on how things
happened for you
in in hindsight how surprising is it to
you that you were able to just post a
tweet or two and boom that's it a
trade's done that night
that's not i mean i'm not surprised
that's that's the world we live in you
know everything is instant instant
gratification instant information it all
travels fast and you
when you dump this when you're dubbed a
series of cars and you have to play your
ace in a hole you play you don't have a
choice you know especially when it comes
down to your life and where you feel
like you want to be on the things you
want for yourself for me i feel like uh
we live in that world i'm not surprised
at all back in the day maybe it wouldn't
happen okay because it wasn't too much
social media or like people having
followers and that kind of thing so i
wasn't too surprised
okay so the situation that's happening
in the nfl now with deshaun watson we
all know the story we we all know he
wants out of houston he hasn't said so
directly
would you advise him to just do what you
did and make it known hey it's time for
a change
cause he doesn't have to i mean the
quarterback position is one of the
positions that's under a huge microscope
uh it's not like being a receiver or
being a tight end being a skilled
position is one thing but being the
quarterback everybody knows when you're
not happy everybody knows where things
are things aren't right you know there's
no rectifying and of course i don't
think he ever has to say you're not
supposed to really say anything up to
that tweet i never said anything i never
said i won out of minnesota um you can
only strongly suggest or create your own
opinions about it and you and i kind of
saw like you know things that happen in
the media people sharing their tidbits
about how they feel this should happen
or how we should handle it um in the
world we live in now you know anybody
who's played professional of any sport
you put a lot of time and effort and
consideration into your job or to what
you do and you want that to be
appreciated you know i don't know the
whole situation with deshaun watson but
obviously he feels away for a reason you
know it didn't it didn't just come out
of nowhere you know i'm obviously
trading down deandre hopkins and that
kind of stuff can kind of play a role in
the quarterback success um and i would
say you know do whatever you got to do
to handle your business and what you
want for yourself for me i was one of
the people that it worked out for
because
of course uh in my opinion um
they didn't think i was going to go to
buffalo and it was going to go well they
didn't know it was going to happen that
way they thought
josh adam was probably an actor if i
thought i was having me weren't going to
mess with or whether for whatever reason
they thought i was a diva but i was one
of those one of the you know few stories
of going into a new chapter or a new
path and it worked out you know so for
me i'm on the back end not really saying
too much because you know it worked out
in my favor god god was great that was
great so i'm blessed
yeah i mean you're you're awesome you
are blessed and yeah you're a damn good
football player i you know just to
piggyback off that a little bit too then
like
why why did it work so much in buffalo
as far as how they used you in the
offense i know it was different i watch
film and do all that but like explain
to the viewer you know the differences
in how buffalo used you and maybe how
you were used up in minnesota
um buffalo and coach dave ball you know
one of the one of
my favorite coaches ever uh getting to
know him learning him and him learning
me he's one of those offensive geniuses
offensive minds that's always trying to
do something new or trying to figure out
ways to do things differently with
window dress and xyz um so for me and it
also was pass heavy we threw the ball a
lot we barely ran the ball and it was it
was total opposite of my previous
situation we ran about you know 80 70
percent of the time so um having that
offensive you know play action and you
know that kind of thing is is it's
it's different you know for me that was
my old offense i i remember and claire's
day you know there's a lot of
play-action a lot of down the field
shots a lot deeper i remember at one
point they were saying like i was one of
the best deep threats of like running
the goal ball and i was like since i got
in the league i would be more so geared
to rock running and that kind of thing
so it's all what what kind of offense
you're in and you know buffalo's more
pass heavy they kind of you know
matriculate down the field or take their
shots when they need to and we just they
just throw the ball a lot so you know
that's all really predicated on our
receivers with a receiver's success if
you throw in a ball well i feel like you
went to a different level this year and
then maybe i'm wrong and maybe it's all
the other but like i interviewed josh
allen before
your indianapolis colts uh or maybe it
was the ravens playoff game and he
basically told me he just goes
if it's one-on-one with diggs he goes
i'm throwing it to him that there's
really not a question so like what about
your own game do you think you improved
too
you know to be that guy now like or or
maybe you think you always you're that
guy
it's
it's such a weird like feeling because
you know since i since i came in the
league i've always been a workaholic
i've always been a guy with something to
prove you know that tip of your shoulder
kind of guy and i put a lot of time in
to be where i'm going now um i've always
considered myself a number one wide
receiver since i got in the league i've
been getting
matched by some of the best receipts
some of the best corners in the game you
know for me it's not a surprise to my
successes more so with the when
preparation met opportunity you know i
was i just was getting a little more
more a couple more opportunities than i
was in my previous situation that's no
showing of my own situation it was just
where their offense was and where they
wanted it to go and how they wanted to
be so being in this new situation i i
didn't i've never changed though i don't
feel like i became a different player i
just became i just felt like i got more
opportunities and i was being utilized
to the best of my ability and when you
utilize uh your talent show you know
whether you can do it or can't you can
you know that's what it comes with a
rubber needs to roll and they they roll
the dice they gave up you know some
draft picks and xyz um for me to get the
job done and that's what that's what i
came to
stefan we had otis anderson used to play
for the giants on the program earlier
this week he told us when scott norwood
of the bills was kicking the field goal
in super bowl 25. he was by the tunnel
because if that kick goes through he's
gone he's not staying out on the field
there's a great picture of you out on
the field after the game against the
chiefs hands on your hips kind of
soaking it all in why did you stay out
there to watch the celebration and what
thoughts what motivations did you have
in that moment
um yeah that's uh
it's tough uh
after the game on the whistle blue i'm a
guy that plays with the blow to the end
of the game um
i was talking about a little bit earlier
i feel like i'm the champion i feel like
i'm the winner you know um the best team
won that day you know and i wanted to
embrace that moment in its totality as
far as like um i'm not a hater i don't
hate on nobody even time and i'm not
that guy to
shun anybody's situation or down i
wanted to embrace that moment as they
were the better team that day and and
you should be motivated you should be
driven to you know go chase the things
that they're that they're after you know
for me it was my second time being one
game away from the super bowl and for me
to tell you that i don't think i'm gonna
be back in that situation i'll be lying
i know i'm gonna be back in this
situation because i know i'm a champion
i know i'm a winner and i know i'm gonna
do everything in my power to get us back
in that situation so
um i just wanted to soak that all up and
soak in that moment and soak in uh all
the good and the bad you know it hurt it
hurt a lot to watch it but uh you need
to see it you need to see it and you
need to evaluate it and use it as a
motivation for you to get to the next
stop
and both of those games where you made
it to the conference championship and it
didn't work out those are road games how
how critical is it for
the bills the next time that level comes
around to be playing that game at home
and not on the road oh my whole video
makes a huge difference people can say
it doesn't matter or whatever when
you're at home you're in your own
stadium you're comfortable you're uh you
don't have to get adjusted to whatever
the wind or however whatever's going on
no excuses but uh it's always good
playing at home because you got that
crowd behind you shout out to bill's
mafia that i haven't had too much time
with but i know when the time comes
they'll be there loud and proud um but
it definitely makes a huge difference
and something that
i
i mean
uh that bill's mafia loves you so don't
worry you're you're you're in the club
you're in the circle of trust all right
what i want to know
is
how much practice did we have to go
through with josh allen to get that
seven minute handshake you guys got
oh yeah go do it yeah right and then you
pat each other on the shoulder i mean
where does that go down when do you find
the time to kind of orchestrate that
it's kind of like a beginning stage of a
handshake where it's super simple like
hey nice to meet you
all right then the closer you get with
somebody the more y'all start developing
a handshake and it starts out super
simple and you kind of got to build on
you know i think weekly we build it off
like he'll be like all right it's time
to ask all right it's time to ask so it
doesn't get old so uh that's one of
those little things that like
relationship builders if i could write a
book about building a relationship with
quarterbacks uh that'd be one of them
get you a handshake
the more success you have the more the
more fun
yeah that that's pretty good there's no
doubt i mean it's special all right one
last thing because i know you got other
stuff to do and you smell and we got to
talk about old spice and how they make
you smell better but with with the
scrambling that's the last thing i want
to ask you about what was the adjustment
like that because i don't think you ever
played with a quarterback that moves the
way he has that had to be somewhat of an
adjustment
yes definitely uh the last quarterback i
had to experiment a lot was i think case
keenum and teddy scrambled a little bit
but those are more guys that were trying
to get the ball out the hands trying to
just make the right decision this guy
was really scrambling to throw the ball
and i seen him make some crazy throws
like you know across your body you know
uh it was a rule that i couldn't go
if he's rolling right i couldn't go left
they say like stop doing it somebody
said i said coach but i'm open and he
can throw it he can throw it he can make
that throw it's like this i don't want
him thrown across his body i know he can
throw the ball he said take your butt to
the silo or do whatever you want but
don't go don't go opposite i was like
all right man josh would give me like a
link to me like this don't worry about
i'll give it to you so
i had to adjust to because i'm i'm
thinking sometimes damn the play's over
like he's about to throw the ball away
like no i need i need to get open again
i need to run another route and try to
figure out a way to get open because
this guy's trying to struggle to throw
it
staphon of all the old spice interviews
that we've done of all the players we've
interviewed over the years i think
you're the first one to go t-shirt over
the hoodie i like the look i may have to
steal it tell us what you got going on
with old spice this year
talk a little bit about their cologne
quality scent uh deodorant you know this
pandemic has been pretty tough on
everybody you know i was on the couch a
couple times like this have i put on
deodorant and it was just uh i'm big oh
hi and me i'm big on hygiene but uh so
for me i'm just talking a little bit
about the deodorant uh dynasty smells
good you know it's available at target i
feel like any everybody on this zoom
call or this car should try it out and
let me know how it goes if i wear it you
guys give it i know you'd give us you
gave me free old spice last year i
believe so you're always good for that i
mean that's that's i missed that we me
and mike we missed the perks of radio
road this year and not getting our free
old spice it really does stink
i think i'm still using the old spice
that i've got like over the years i've
never had to buy any because every time
we do one of these they send me a bag
full of old spice stuff i'm still
working on it so i hope to get another
bag of old spice dynasty products stefan
as always man it's great to see you
congratulations on your phenomenal year
and we wish you all the best we hope
next year we can't talk to you we hope
next year your you're otherwise occupied
this week don't call me don't talk to me
i don't want to hear nothing
man step on see you bud
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports